I bought a samurai sword didn't even
remember until I received and opened the
package that was a fun day
one hundred and eighty dollars worth of
fake urine my brother night drunk
discussed it for about an hour in the
end it seemed like a good idea
a circus themed tent for my cat it has a
tiny flag on top
I bought a six cup food processor a pair
of knee-high bumblebee socks and a
coloring book called dinosaurs with jobs
ordered an eight-foot cardboard cutout
of Will Ferrell and arranged for it to
be sent to my mother's house a friend of
mine has gotten absurdly drunk and
ordered things on Amazon she likes to be
surprised
twelve vibrators later and she's finally
started canceling the orders because it
is literally always a vibrator I woke up
one morning after a hell of a happy hour
to see an email confirmation from around
3:30 a.m. for my purchase of fencing
lessons my best friend and I woke up one
morning to an email confirming our
purchase of tickets to see Hanson I'll
admit I love Hanson but this was the
worst show due to the other fans no one
should have an inn Bobcat to no one one
Saturday night I decided that instead of
going to church in the morning I would
order a package of 1,000 communion
wafers online a Nicolas Cage as Mona
Lisa iPhone case I was so proud of drunk
me when it arrived